SUBJECT: So the
smartphone revolution,
the revolution in
connectivity, has
created an on-demand economy.
As Kevin Kelly
says, access is now
more important than
ownership, the idea
that goods and services are
just a rub on a magic mirror
away from being fulfilled.
This notion of extending
our will, magic,
as Aleister Crowley described
it, as willed intent.
I summon, and it appears.
As I imagine, so it becomes.
And this is the very essence of
magic, which is a great line.
And this is the world
that we're living in now.
Services like Uber,
services like Airbnb,
that will literally summon the
ability to go stay somewhere
and the means to get there
at the speed of thought,
almost, are scaling
to the point that we
are seeing a transformation
in our phenomenological
experience.
We are creating a
technologically-mediated flow
where most of the world becomes
an extension of our agency.
I mean, even the fact that
Uber can sync with your Spotify
playlist, so that when
you summon the car
to take you to the place
that you want to go,
the car arrives and the
music that you've previously
soundscaped is already
playing in the car,
giving you the serendipitous
experience of moving
into spaces where all of a
sudden, everything's amazing.
This is the song I like.
This is the place I want to go.
Oh, let's go somewhere.
Oh, here's the
car picking me up.
Oh my god, I want to go stay at
this beautiful mountain town.
Oh my god, here's the
apartment waiting for me.
Just an Airbnb again.
I mean, this on-demand economy
is transforming subjectivity.
When we surrender into
it, when we surrender
into the space and the
speed of the feedback
loops between our
creative choices
and what is able to be summoned
through our technological
extensions, our
technological scaffoldings,
we actually step into a
new space of consciousness.
We step into a new way
of perceiving reality.
The whole thing becomes
mental architecture.
We cognitize the world.
That's the AI revolution.
That is the on-demand economy.
We extend our cognition, our
mental neuroarchitecture,
out into the world.
It all becomes dream space.
It all becomes elusive dream.
It all becomes an inception
that we can control.
That's what's promised
by the on-demand economy.
I find it very exciting.
Very exciting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]